só hoje vai continuar a fazer este mini
besta fiz maneira mais simples possível
como é que vocês consigam fazê lá em
casa e pronto agora de seguida o
tutorial
acho que ficou muito bem feito e pronto
vocês quiserem e puderem usar óculos de
proteção e pronto pode ter a companhia
reduz a cmb tem interesse sim muita
força mesmo explorando todo cuidado é
pouco
mas o historial está na revista
digam lá se machucou muito e fazer essa
mini bmw convite como este que elas
podem comprar ou então nunca foi
qualquer f tem mais ou menos uns dez que
fazer o arco
o fio foi o que eu sei é um fio dental é
muito resistente 70 curvaram fellini o
paciente estrutura para incorporar o aro
fez um corte de um terço mas somente ver
até onde fica o parque do povo o gatilho
que é uma bola daquelas usava usadas nas
florestas para prender o católico mas já
que a bola e branco
agora vamos pular na bola e chutar para
fora em contato pra gente usar uma cola
instantânea para mandar para aqui um
pauzinho para churrasco pode usar
tamanho popular que maneira fazer um
canal para depois que está agora em cima
desta página
a quem mais difícil segurar vai texto 42
convalescer de uma cola instantânea na
internet traz também fica mais feliz e
agora por guaru mesma mãe e na direita e
está outro vídeo circulando com ele lá
pra baixo pra segurar o arco já
encostado
essa placa fazer os ajustes podem fazer
o ato leu algumas alterações para frente
enquanto estou maravilhado feito em água
quente porque fica assim muito mais
viável e está agora na reforma
quando você está em campo e com a escola
e só espero conseguir fazer a minha
besta e que tiveram muita atenção aos
responsáveis por cima tudo e pronto você
desligar em fazer de você
nesta parte criança anunciar que cria
uma parceria com márcia invenções o
canal do gabriel e pronto gabriel faz
vídeos de quatro anos como os mesmos ou
seja na mesma categoria de dicas e
tutoriais e pronto você quiser ver um
vídeo de eu carreguei neste quadrado ou
retangular uacs ver e pronto se quiser
ver mais um vídeo pronto para tentar
embaixo e pronto é isso só eu e até o
próximo vídeo